اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
الكل متهمون والجميع يتنصلون من يقف وراء
تفجير خط نورستيم وما هي تداعيات تحديد
هويته
صراع خفي على خلافه المرشد في ايران لمن
تذهب السلطه رجل دين ام منظومه امنيه
عسكريه
وفي الملف الثالث بعد زلازل تركيا وسوريا
ما مدى صحه الشائعات عن هزات المدمره تهدد
المنطقه العربيه
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى الملف الاول منذ سبتمبر
الماضي يشعل تفجير خطاي انابيب نورسين
حربا من التجهنات حول المتورطين في تفجير
خطاي انابيب الغاز اللذان يربطان روسيا
والمانيا كما يشتد تبادل الاتهامات بين
العديد من الاطراف حول الجهه المنفذه
السلطات الالمانيه كشفت سابقا عن سفينه
يشتبه بانها نقلت مواد ناسفه الى موقع
التفجيرات في بحر البلطيق واستخدمت تلك
المواد في تفجير خطي الانابيب فيما لفت
مكتب المدعي العام في ضرر الالماني حديثا
الى انه فتش منتصف شهري يناير سفينه
المشتبه بها وان السلطات تقيم المواد
المضبوطه سته اشهر والاتهامات متبادله
ولكن مؤخرا اثار تقريران اعلاميان احدهما
لنيويورك تايمز والاخر لهيئه البث
الالمانيه بترجيح وقوف مجموعه اوكرانيه او
مواليه لاوكرانيا خلف التفجير مع تورط
اوكرانيا رسميا بالامر وافادت هيئه البث
العام الالمانيه بان طاقمين من سته اشخاص
مجهولي الجنسيه استاجروا قاربا من شركه
يملكها اوكرانيون لتنفيذ عمليه التخريب
ومع ذلك فدائره الاتهام تتسع بعد ان شملت
روسيا واوكرانيا وبريطانيا والولايات
المتحده وجديده او جديدها قال انهم موالون
لاوكرانيا فيما يصر البعض انه للعثور على
الفاعل الحقيقي يجب البحث اولا عن
المستفيد الحقيقي من هذا التفجير
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكو سرقه
المحلل العسكري ومن واشنطن حسين عبد
الحسين الباحث في مركز الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من موسكو معك سيد شاشكور في
الواقع رغم اهميه عمليه عمليه التفجير
وتداعيات التي تبعناها كلنا ولكن يقول
مراقبون بان هناك اخفاق في التحقيق
وايجاد المتورط الحقيقي من يقف وراء كل
هذا لماذا وكانه هناك برود في محاوله
ايجاد الفاعل هل يتنصل المجتمع الدولي من
محاوله التحقيق ومدافع وراء ذلك
اهلا بك
قريبا
الارهابي يعني تفجير ثلاث خطوط من
خطين واحد واثنين
والتحقيق
يقال وارد ولكن التحقيق هذا
تحقيق غريب لان اولا طلبت روسيا باعتبارها
صاحب المشروع
والدوله التي خسرت
النفقات
تزيد قيمتها 12 مليار دولار
مع
ايضا مع
خساره بعض الشركات الالمانيه التي كانت
تشارك في تنفيذ هذا المشروع طلبت روسيا
بالمشاركه في هذا التحقيق وايجاد الحقيقه
وكان الجواب من قبل لجنه التحقيق الغربيه
رفض رفضا قطعا همم
اليوم سمعنا الى بعد التصريحات
كانت
تريدنا من واشنطن التي يمكن وصفها
كاسطوره كان من الممكن ان تسمى بمضحكه لا
تلك الدريات والخسائر الماديه البالغه
التاثيرات
المتكونه على
التطورات العالميه على السعيد العالمي
طبعا له
نظرنا الى صلب هذه الاسطوره الامريكيه
فتقول ان هناك مفرز من ست اشخاص ربما تكون
اوكران او روس اوكرانيين وروس مع بعض
وعددهم سته وعلى راسه بامراه فواصلوا الى
مناف بولندا واجر زورق وتمكنوا من تحميله
120 او 140 كيلوغرام من المتفجرات وواصلوا
الى النطاق الاقتصادي الداخلي في المياه
الاقليميه الدنماركيه وفاجروا هذا الخط
واختفى
وكانها شائعات تروج لها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه دكتور حسين هل فعلا تروج
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لقصاص دون ان
تكون فعليا مهتمه بايجاد المتورط الحقيقي
ضيف يقول بانه روسيا تطلب وتستبسل في هذا
الطلب ولكن ليس هناك قبول غربي
مساء الخير ست ريم هذه حرب والحروب يعني
ليست وكانها مخالفه سير او او كانه يعني
قام شخص بالاعتداء على واجهه محلات لدوله
اخرى هناك حرب مندلعه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وروسيا قامت بتدمير جزء كبير من البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه والارجح انه اوكرانيا
ايضا سعت الى تدمير بنيه تحتيه روسيا طبعا
هذه الانابيب هي ملكيه الدوله الروسيه هل
قام الاوكرانيون وحدهم بتنفيذ هذا التفجير
هل كان هناك خبراء غربيين هل كان هناك
مرتزقه غربيين حتى طبعا كما تفضل السيد
شوشكوفل يعني الموضوع ليس بهذه البساطه
ليس ليس لدى معظم الدول القدره على تنفيذ
هذه الاعمال من التفجير في مواقع بعيده
لديهم القدره على التحقيق
بدايه يجب الاشاره الى ان روسيا لا تزال
تواصل دخ النفط والغاز عبر الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى اوروبا حتى في ايامنا هذه
وحتى الان يعني اثناء بث هذا البرنامج
هناك نفط روسي يستبير عبر الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى الغرب هذا اولا ثانيا
عندما يقول المتحدث الرسمي الامريكي ان لا
نستبعد اي شيء
وربما كانت هذه المفرز المرتبطه ومموله
باحد الاوكرانيين الاغنياء طبعا اي اسم او
جماعه او حزب او تحرك اي شيء لا معلومه
اطلاقا فعندما يقول اننا نستبعد اي شيء لو
قال ذلك المتحدث ان المفرزه وصلت من
القرن القمر وبعد تنفيذ العمليه راحت الى
المريخ نعم اصدق هذه
الروايه اقرب بكثير من الحقيقه الان اذا
رجعنا للسلب الموضوع اي جريمه لها
الشخص او مجموعه او طرف رابح فبين رابح
بين مباراه تنفيذ هذه الامعاليه طبعا كانت
هناك اتصالات متينه ووثيقه بين روسيا
والمانيا الان بعد توجيه هذه الخط المانيا
تضطر على شراء الغاز المسيل من الولايات
المتحده بسعر يزيد على سعر الغزل الروسي
اربعه ضعف فاديا فاديا في تلك المنطقه
كانت هناك اربع خطوط غاز ثلاثه من روسيا
انا خطيت
واحد اخر
وارد من نربج الى المانيا يعني كيف
تلك الجماعه تمكنوا من ايجاد هدافيات
الخطوط وتفجير الخط المطلوب
وخيار صحيح بين هذا وهذاك يعني عمليه هذه
صعبه حتى يبدو مستحيله بحسب رايك ولكن
ارى تعبير مع دكتور حسين وكان معك تعليق
دكتور على هذا الموضوع وكانك لا ترى صعوبه
وترى بان الموضوع قادر ان يحبك بطريقه
معينه
طبعا انا يعني اوافق انه علينا البحث عن
المستفيد ولكن الولايات المتحده ليست من
الدول التي تستحي بما تسعى اليه الرئيس
السابق ترامب كان يعلن صراحه اولا هو فرض
عقوبات على استكمال بناء
وحاولت حتى اداره اوباما ساعدت هذا
المانيا لوقت هذه الانابيب ليس لمواضيع
يعني الغاز الامريكي فحسب وانما انه كانوا
يقولون لالمانيا انه ان اعتمدتم على الغاز
الروسي سيكون لبوتين قدره على يعني لي
ذراعكم خصوصا مع قدوم الشتاء في المواضيع
الاستراتيجيه
فالولايات المتحده لا تستحي هي تعارض هذا
الانبوب وهي طالبت اوروبا بنصر مرافق في
البرتغال وانابيب من البرتغال الى فرنسا
ولكن نحن نتحدث وكانها عوضت هذا الرفض
يعني رفضت في الاول ولكن فيما بعد يقول
ضيفي بانها استثمرت في عمليه التفجير هي
التي باعت الغاز الى اوروبا باربعه اضعاف
كانت هناك تصريحات قويه لماكرون في هذا
الشان
لا انا طبعا انا يعني اقول انه الولايات
المتحده طبعا هي من الولايات المتحده
ومصلحه كل الدول المصدره للغاز في العالم
بما في ذلك يعني ايران وقطر واسرائيل ومصر
وكل هذه الدول تستفاد انه خرجت روسيا من
سوق الغاز ولكن انا اقول انه الولايات
المتحده لا تقوم باعمال يعني على على هذا
النمط هي ربما مستفيده هي ربما سهلت هي
ربما سهلت لمجموعه اوكرانيه يعني عدد من
المرتزقه الامريكيين قاموا بتسهيل لانه
هذه عمليه معقده كما يتفضل السيد شوشكوب
ولكن الحكومه الامريكيه لا تقوم يعني هذا
الموضوع لا لا يمكن ان يخبئ في واشنطن
يعني
ان قام
امريكي محقق امريكي بصفع يعني فرد كف في
سجن حول العالم في غوانت غير ذلك يعرف
الاعلام الامريكي ويتحول الى صفحه اولى
فهذه المواضيع لا يمكن ان تخبئ ولكنك نقطه
مهمه دكتور حسين حضرتك تقول بانها يمكن ان
تكون سهلت يمكن ان تكون استاجرت مرتزقه
ووقفت وراء هذه العمليه ما الذي يحرجها
اليوم باختصار حتى انقل نفس هذا السؤال
لضيف السيد تشكوف ما الذي يحرجها اليوم في
فتح هذا التحقيق هل هو امكانيه ان تتورط
حتى من خلال التسهيل
لا اعتقد انه يعني انسهلت لن تكون سهلت
كحكومه وطبعت السيد شوشكوب اشار الى
امكانيه قيام متمولين كبار من اوكرانيا
بتمويل هذه العمليه يعني كل ما يحتاج
الامر الى يعني مال وفريق يتمتع بخبره
وليس بالضروره هذا الفريق ينتمي للحكومه
ولكن انا احاول الاشاره اليه انه امريكا
ضد هذا الموضوع لكن هي لو ارادت هي تفجيره
يعني القيام بالتفجير كان هناك ادوات
متعدده ومصاب وستعمل
ستعلن او لا تعلن لا نعلم حساباته في هذه
المرحله ولكن
ما رايك في هذه الروايه وهي روايه الارجح
مراقبون يقولون بان واشنطن قد تكون وراء
هذه العمليه بطريقه
او باخرى هل يمكن ان تكون هذه الروايه هي
الاقرب
اريد ان اذكركم بالتصريحات الرسميه التي
اذن بها الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن شخصيا
وبمستوى مفتوح اعلاميا واكثر من ثلاث مرات
في العمل المنصارم حيث قال ان لن نسمح
بوضع هذا
التنفيذ هذا الخد استراتيجي بين روسيا
والمانيا لن يعمل
واشار الى ذلك رسميا ثلاث مرات على الاقل
فقال ان سوف نقوم بكل ما في وسعنا لمنع
هذا
لمنع تنفيذ هذا المشروع وهذا ما حدث
فيما يفوز بالمصالح طبعا المصلحه الغربيه
هي واضحه انه
الان المانيا
اصبحت
معتمده تماما على شراء الغاز والنفط
بالنرويج والولايات المتحده وقطر ودول
اخرى
وتشتريها باسعار تزيد على اسعار سابقه
يعني مقارنه مع الدفتر الروسيه
والان حتى الاقتصاد الى الماني وهو من
اقوى
[موسيقى]